[Musique]
faire de la lutte contre le chômage
bien sûr c'est une priorité le
département ne peut pas rester à l'écart
de ce combat qui concerne l'ensemble des
réunionnais et j'ai signé cette
convention avec grand plaisir avec
monsieur layton pas l'emploi pour
montrer notre volonté justement d'aller
le plus loin possible dans la recherche
de solution et cela passe par lorsqu'il
est une commande publique passée par le
département qu'on puisse faire appel
justement à des personnes sans activité
pour que ces personnes puissent
travailler sur nos chantiers pour
lesquels nous passons des commandes
j'ai rencontré j'ai eu le plaisir de
rencontrer le président du département
pour aborder un certain nombre de sujets
nos différents partenariats les projets
en cours et on en a effectivement
profité pour signer une convention sur
les clauses d'insertion
cette signature permet de mettre en
avant des candidatures de demandeurs
d'emploi qui en plus de problématiques
de difficultés dans le cadre de la
commande publique c'est un des critères
importants de choix pour les personnes
qui vont travailler avec la avec le
département dont pont c'est un outil qui
est vraiment important
ça nous permet de mettre en avant de
présenter plus encore les candidats ou
les demandeurs d'emploi il est proposé
donc leurs compétences aux fournisseurs
je mets le montre guillemets du conseil
départemental
[Musique]